the ACM Awards took over the star in
Frisco Texas and all eyes were on
country music's new rock star
s
second consecutive year as host how are
you feeling right now I feel good I got
a lot of clothes to change anything we
counted six different outfits from a
cowgirl looking jeans to a Glam floral
gown the go to Country paired with the
real thing did I hear say you rocking
for a goat and to close the show
this billowing map of the world dress
covering the entire stage as Dolly
addressed Global division debuting her
first ever rock song world on fire and
got everyone on their feet
[Music]
I'm introducing my whole Rock album
tonight yeah and this is the first
single from that but it's a good message
I think everybody in the world needs to
kind of hear this your Rockstar album
cover art
OMG you look like a vixen well I tried
really hard to look like a rock star we
will always love oh thank you
first time hosting did you shake off all
the nerves feel good you get to talk
about country music I can do that all
night long co-host Garth Brooks and his
wife Trisha Yearwood had a dolly Love
Fest from the carpet to the stage I saw
you online telling all those nice people
out there that I'm your hall pass and
that I'm Trish's Hall passion
Garth organized a threesome
what does this mean you're gonna have
people talking after this everybody
loves Dolly actually people think this
is Dolce Gabbana but it's Dolly and
Garth so
the threesome's already getting started
y'all
Trisha had her own fangirl backstage
Nicole Kidman then performed a medley
ever hits with Carly Pierce including
this one from 1991.
[Music]
what does it feel like to be out there
Everybody Knows lyrics to your song you
know it reminds me the first time when I
was 26 years old singing that song and
the first time I saw people singing the
lyrics like they know this song because
they've heard me sing on the radio and
it feels the same all these years later
it was so fun it was over so fast I was
like did that just happen it was so fun
also having fun Lainey Wilson who was
hand in hand with her new man a former
Steelers quarterback Devlin duck Hodges
I brought me a hot date tonight I sure
did I mean he's looking like a a snack
over there ain't he a snack of a cowboy
I know I said you can be my date but you
can't steal my thunder so you're all
fired we've all been on pins and needles
about the Fate for Yellowstone whether
or not it's coming back what is the deal
I'm waiting for that call I'm like y'all
let me know when to be there and I'll be
there how is Kevin riding off into the
sunset lady oh my gosh well Lainey was
riding High taking home four Awards
including female artists of the year
girl you had four deaths Heart Take
you're so sweet
[Music]
Keith Urban and Nicole Kidman made it to
date night even sharing this sweet
moment holding hands before Keith's
opening number Anna Nicole was ready for
it
take this time
I've got my glitter on I have fun and
dance tonight because every shower musty
Lambert New York Times best-selling
author how are you doing good how are
you are you so proud of this moment
[Music]
was all smiles alongside Miranda Lambert
Florida Georgia Line's Brian Kelly and
his wife Brittany were color coordinated
for the big party and Tyler Hubbard hit
the carpet an hour after his band mate
twinning with his wife Haley you and
your wife are looking
[Music]
Kane Brown and his duet partner wife
Caitlin thank God for giving me you
won't be gonna get a follow-up
oh we're working on we're putting out a
studio in the house right now so we're
gonna put the babies to bed and just
work on some music
[Music]
Dell
is at life hitting the carpet for the
first time with his new fiancee Courtney
little I'm already a winner before I
even got here you blacked out when you
were proposing oh man wasn't anybody
Chris Stapleton had a lot to celebrate
too winning the coveted Entertainer of
the Year award for its first time my
kids sitting at home
they give up a lot of my time a lot of
my wife's time so we can go do this and
uh this is for them he said tonight it
was for your kids your family how do you
make Road life comfortable for you we do
the best we can you know and and we're
taking the whole circus this year all
the little guys too so no way oh yeah
how many do you and Morgan have we have
five
yeah Morgan Wallen two days after Morgan
postponed his tour and began six weeks
of vocal rest he took home male artist
of the year Garth accepted the award on
his behalf to win it is one thing to be
here not to get it must be killing him
have you talked to Morgan how's he doing
he's doing fine I know he's just laying
low and protecting his voice I had sex
with him a little bit yesterday just
hope he gets to feeling better soon and
get back on the road
I'm in the middle of the this is
where I belong y'all right here I am
with my kind I started drinking at noon
baby we showed up like hello well hello
Jelly Roll the country newcomer was so
fired up for the big night he Moonwalks
for our cameras while getting ready to
hit the stage with Lainey Wilson
stapleton's sitting right in front of me
out there no matter how good I sing I'm
gonna think I suck
Old Dominion baby come on where's the
six trophy sitting I put it in my glove
box so in case I get pulled over I pull
it out hopefully get me out of a ticket
it's a six feet for Old Dominion winning
group of the year then check out this
Duo party in backstage before they
premiered this duet
[Music]
Ed did just reveal he would quote love
to transition to country as for Luke
he's got his hands full at home 202 is
going to be interesting we got it though
I'm excited
Luke's life Nicole wasn't the only
country lady rocking a baby bump there
were eight soon to be dead of three
Jordan Davis performed Kimberly Perry
showed off her bump in this black and
silver number my little baby boy is
enjoying his first red carpet his red
carpet debut
it was also Mom and Dad's night out for
Gabby Barrett and her hubby Cade and new
parents Jon Pardi and wife summer a
little baby Presley she's awesome she's
a great baby she flew on the plane
didn't cry that's a win
now I saw on the gram she was in some
car Hearts you guys were working on
building a new house she was driving a
tractor I mean you got big hopes for
this girl she's gonna be tough
[Music]
my wife Lucy can't be here tonight we
just had twins and leave it to the
Brothers Osborne to have no filter but
lots of fun John come out of these award
shows without kids before he'd be like
wow this is so much work but now he
comes here and he's like wow what a
break
so we're it's the word vacation
he's got a boy and a girl we knocked it
all out we're done I think right loose
we're done right well not Liz actually
she told me that does she wants more
yeah all right enjoy having a family
with someone else
[Music]
thank you